who am I I became curious about the self
when I read Brian Lowry's new book
selfless the social creation of you and
the fascinating thing about the self is
it's created by others and empowered
through our relationships and
communication
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to a quick
thinks episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast
to learn more we invited Brian Lowry
back Brian is a professor at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business and
he also co-directs Stanford's Institute
of race
Brian it is fantastic to have you back
you certainly have been really really
busy I'm excited to listen regularly to
your new podcast and today I got my copy
of your book
selfless the social creation of you I
want to probe that idea in a second but
I'm tantalized and intrigued by what
follows the colon of your title the
social creation of you can you share a
little bit about what's behind that
of course so in social science people
will say the self is a social
construction and what they really mean
is who you are is created by the
relationships and people around you and
what's amazing about that is very few
people have that experience of
themselves like most people I assume you
to have this sense of like I'm in my
head looking out of my eyes making
decisions talking to people sometimes I
make good with sometimes bad ones but
I'm in there somewhere but when you
examine it you know that can't be true
there's no little you in there and so
the question becomes what are you what
are you and answer now something like my
brain but that's not quite right either
I'm this physical thing because your
physical thing changes all the time but
you don't have the sense that that's you
that you have now changed because
there's been some physical change I'm
not making the book is that the you
you're talking about is the
relationships you have the social
interactions you have in the cultural
context do you exist in that isn't
affecting you that is constituting who
you are that is who you are and in that
sense
self and this is really important part
of the book The self is incompatible
with freedom the way most people
understand it because the self is a
constraint the self is a definition in
terms of the way other people see you to
be a man to be black or white to be
Asian or to be a doctor all these things
are about how people understand you and
interact with you and limit what you can
be and in limiting what you can be
they make you who you are
wow there's so much there to unpack so
if I heard you correctly it's we are the
the sum of the relationships we have and
by definition of those relationships how
people Define us that limits what we
potentially could be are there things we
can do to work to change how people see
us or perhaps the people we associate
with to give us a little bit more
freedom is that possible
you know this is a you have to read the
book I will I will but I think
fundamentally a self and ultimate
Freedom are incompatible
and that so for some people that sounds
bad because Freedom has at least in our
culture this kind of virtue associated
with it like everybody wants freedom and
more freedom is just better but that's
I'd argue that's not true people don't
really believe that meaning that it
feels good to have people know you like
when you engage with someone and they
engage with you in a way that feels
right and you feel seen people love that
and need that but that requires
limitations on what you are that is an
acceptance of an absence of a certain
type of Freedom so I think people don't
really want freedom in the way they
imagine they do or not as much as they
think they do and the way you can
expand and I think the self is
fundamentally a limiting idea but that
doesn't mean it can't be expanded you
can expand it by engaging with more
people with diverse perspectives because
it turns out and there's research on
this that we actually take other
people's selves into our own so you
think about your closest relationships
you can think about how much overlap is
there between you and that person right
and the closest relationship the more
people will say there's overlap in who
we are and so you can expand the self by
deepening the relationships you have
I certainly know in my closest
relationships with my wife my kids my
close friends that there is the taking
on of other characteristics I'm curious
so in in graduate school when I was
studying relationships and communication
within relationships there was this
notion that you and the person you're in
relationship with are your individual
selves but together you create a
collective self is that something that
resonates with your point of view or is
that something that's archaic and back
from the good old days when I was in
school well I guess what I would say is
like I don't know what the individual
self is in the way that's described so I
think people have this idea of mine
exist as an island and I bump into other
islands and then we can create something
together what I would say is you are in
some sense an amalgamation a combination
a mixture of all those relationships and
whenever you interact with someone
there's a there's a an exchange of Self
in some way so I can give you an example
and in terms of research so if you meet
someone you have of beliefs about what
they believe right so you see someone I
don't know they're driving a truck and
they have an American flag you have a
belief about this person they might be
right it might not be right right if you
want to have a relationship with that
person associations you have in your own
head that you might not even be aware of
that you might not even know are there
will shift in the direction of your
belief about that other person's
attitudes so in some sense yourself is
changing to accommodate other people
because you won't have a relationship
with them that to have a relationship
with someone
demands in some sense a shift in who you
currently are so in that way there's an
inner meshing of cells that happens at a
level that you're not even aware of and
probably aren't controlling and that is
what's happening all the time in our
lives as we navigate the world and then
close relationships it's more intense so
Brian that's absolutely fascinating to
me because part of what I heard you say
is that we have this construction of
ourselves that feels permanent like I
know who I am but in fact it's
constantly changing and in some cases
I'm choosing to change it by choosing to
engage with someone are there things I
can do in the moment when I'm in that
situation meeting somebody new or or
deepening a relationship that I have
that I could perhaps prepare myself
better to expand that connection a
relationship
yeah so one is put your phone down
he means in theory I don't have my phone
right now
approach relationships with curiosity
that's actually really important and
three here's here's a maybe one that
will be a bit surprising to people we
often are afraid to ask what we consider
personal questions because we think it's
going to upset other people right we
imagine if we ask this question they're
gonna they're gonna be like who are you
to ask me that question whether they say
it or not they will be thinking that and
we want to avoid that discomfort it
turns out the research suggests that
people actually are not put off by what
most people think of as personal
questions and so you can ask more
intimate questions than you imagine so
I'm not going to say go out and ask the
most answering question you can imagine
but I would say move towards asking more
personal questions than you might
imagine you could just a step further
and that provides an opportunity to
initiate a more meaningful interaction
even if it doesn't become a relationship
we don't it's seriously enough some of
the light interactions we have day to
day and those things turn out to affect
our mood is affected by the fleeting
interactions we have that we don't take
that seriously so another thing to do is
in one curiosity two be willing to ask
questions that may be a little bit more
a step more personal than you typically
would and three take more seriously
those fleeting interactions that you
often just think of as a toss away those
are very actionable and in underlying at
least two of the three bits of advice
are communication and you know that's
something we focus a lot on here Brian
I'm really intrigued by this notion that
we can benefit by probing a little
deeper and getting a little more
personal in conversations I think you're
right many of us feel awkward and
uncomfortable especially if we're not
really close to the people we're talking
to do you have advice or guidance that
you've seen in your own life or you've
recommended to people about types of
questions or ways to do that inquiry I
should just say this is not my ideas
there's research on this and I I'll send
you the site you can put it up on the
website so if you can read read the
academic paper I don't want to I want to
make sure that people get credit for
their ideas
one of the things that I think about is
asking people like when we interact with
people like that we don't know very well
we often ask very very superficial
questions how's the weather what do you
where are you going to go have you been
on this to this place I think
one question that is easy to ask people
that it's not that personal but it takes
you a little a little bit deeper is what
are you most excited about in life right
now right I mean there's they're just
easy questions you can ask that no one
would be a thing bothered by and then
once they answer it's like follow-up
questions become much easier
um you know the way you form
relationships is reciprocal escalating
disclosure so I don't know if you've
talked about that but if people haven't
heard it it's just like someone says
something to you they disclose a little
bit and then when you reciprocate you
disclose a little bit more and it
escalates that's the way that people
basically form relationships so you
think about relationships in your life
that's often how they happen
and what you want to do is initiate that
right with someone new and so finding a
way to sometimes ask
for disclosure that people feel
comfortable with and then reciprocating
a step deeper as a way to kick off a
relationship a way to expand like what
you know about that person what they
know about you so you start by
expressing curiosity at a slightly
deeper level and then reciprocate but
when you get a response the final
question I'm curious how has yourself
changed in doing the work that you've
done in terms of writing the book the
podcast the teaching that you do it
seems to me that by your definition of
self it must have changed oh it has to
right right so I'm taking your advice
for granted asking a slightly more
personal question I'm just curious
that's a good question one thing that I
in writing a book I became something
else and I still don't know what that
something else is I'm like a baby in
this in this new self and it generates
an appreciation for what it means for
the self to constantly evolve and change
I think we often don't really pay enough
attention to the ways we change and
maybe we're hard on ourselves than we
should be like I'm I'm brand new at this
thing but it's not just this thing it's
to some extent who I am and how people
are engaging with me and how I'm
engaging with them and trying to figure
all that out is is not easy and I think
there's a degree of compassion I've
learned in writing this book When
people's identities are both challenged
their sense of self is challenged and or
it shifts or grows there's a recognition
of when we engage with people we are
asking something of them and I I think I
have a better appreciation for that for
the requests that my person makes of
other people right of the ones that I
make of other people
and what that demands for others and
also when people do it to me what it
it's an offer I think of it as an
opportunity and an offer that that
person is making to me an offer of
expansion and I can accept or reject
that for whatever reasons but it is an
offer I really appreciate that you've
come to a realization or explored
something that that we talked about many
many
episodes ago in the terms of
improvisation that that life and
Encounters in life can be perceived as
opportunities and offers and they allow
you to expand and I think that's really
interesting and the other thing that
caught my mind is there are certain
situations in our lives where there's a
gate that changes ourselves like you've
published a book you are now an author
yourself has changed and then there are
other things that happen in our lives
that are much more subtle that change us
I mean those of us who have become
parents when your child is born that's a
change in self I recall back when I
graduated college and even graduate
school it felt like this big change I
was working for and nothing really
changed and you know it was I had this
thing on the wall you know so what
you've made me think about is how our
self changes constantly and yet
sometimes it's very significant and
publicly noticed and other times it's
very subtle and not noticed and
sometimes things we think are big
changes end up not being you've made me
think a lot Brian and that's what I
appreciate so much about you your
podcast know what you see and your looks
selfless the social creation of you
really do make us think and I appreciate
that and I appreciate your time today
thank you thank you so much for having
me it was fun to talk to you again
excellent
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn